やぁーゴールデンウィークかぁ
なんとなくで海来ちゃったけど
いざ祝日ってなってもやることないんだよなぁ〜
海沿いでなんか面白そうな出会いとかねぇーかなぁ〜
（そわそわしているたなっち）
（何かを発見）
ああっ！
はじめ）あの本当は…
所沢とドライブする予定だったんスよ
ゴールデンウィーク
たなっち）あぁ
はじめ）けどなんか〜
車に乗んなくて
たなっち）あはは
はじめ）デカすぎてちょっと車に乗んなかったんで
所沢の彼女のめぐみちゃんと
ドライブしようかなって
いつもさ家の中にいるから嫌なんスよ
たなっち）なるほどね
はじめ）あんま外出たくなかったんスけど
今日だけは…
ははは、すごーい！なに！？って言われてるｗ
はじめんウインク☆キラン
たなっち）スカしてましたよ　ちゃんと
はじめ）そう俺スカした
はじめ）おー今日はいいだろう
はじめ）はっはｗｗ
たなっち）ははは
ドップラー効果みたいに
はじめ）はじめしゃちょーだぁ〜
はじめ）あ、やっぱ怒られないんだ
たなっち）怒られない
はじめ）怒られない
たなっち）あはは
はじめ）笑い声が絶えない
たなっち）まぁでも警察の人も
はじめ）許容してるってこと？
たなっち）なんも問題ないよーって感じ
はじめ）よかったー
はじめ）マジぬいぐるみ
はじめ）置いていて捕まるのだけは勘弁だ本当に
なんかオープンカーに
おっきい熊のぬいぐるみを乗せて
運転したいんですけど
そうですね
なるほどなるほど
そうです、安全の確保をしたうえで
ってことですよね
はい、失礼いたします
大丈夫そうだねｗ
たなっち）はじめ〜
はじめ）はっはは
はじめ）今ねードライブしてんの
はじめ）うん
はじめ）ありがとね
はじめ）すげーまぁ今日だけは写真を許そう
はじめ）ありがとう
はじめ）ははははは
はじめ）え〜？
男の子）あ、はじめしゃちょー
はじめ）これゾーン入ってるね
たなっち）なんかゾーン入ってます
はじめ）ゾーン入ってる
はじめ）こんにちは
はじめ）あーこんにちは
はじめ）え？ うまい棒？はい
女の子）ありがとーう
女性）本当なの？すごーい
はじめ）みんいいゴールデンウィークを
すごすんやああ
男の子）ばいばーい
はじめ）ばいばーい
はい、というわけでめぐみちゃんとの
ゴールデンウィークデートしてきました
いやーなんか久しぶりにゆっくりできたというか
まぁこの子もいつも家の中にいるんで
久しぶりに外に出れて楽しかったのでは
ないでしょうか
はじめ）よかったね
たなっち）よかったですね
はじめ）しゃーラーメンでも食いに行きますか
たなっち）行きましょう
はじめ）オープンカーだから閉じないとね　ちゃんと
たなっち）誘拐されちゃう
はじめ）あぁん
（めぐみ:あ、痛いよはじめん）
はじめ）おいおいおい！ああ！！あっ
はじめ）めぐみぃーーーーーー
【はじめしゃちょーエンディングテーマ】
たなっち）ひかっ、ヒカキン
はじめ）ヒカキン
はじめ）ヒカキンではないです